yesterday I was pleading for Occam's  razor clear-thinking rules of evidence  because you know if hearsay and excited  rumor is all it takes to sway you toward  leaving in a dwelt planet or aliens  trading coaxial cables for fetal tissue  or all the better you're just going to  be a victim that you're going to be a  mark somebody's picking your pocket you  know we can do better than that in the  great centuries of academic thinking and  technical innovation then just on you  know people who support unanchored and  unhinged and tasteless and over design  speculation if the truth will be  beautiful and it will be simple and it  will be persuasive to those who doubt it  so don't get into some closed-loop of  ideologies make the truth seduce you  don't be thereby seduced by error  [Applause]